welcome back to New Rockstars it's me Mt
and remember in quantumania when Kang
told his army that he wanted revenge on
the Council of Kings by conquering
eternity what the hell did he mean by
that how does one go ahead and Conquer
eternity and could Kane want revenge on
eternity themselves let's talk about a
speculation Nation But first you guys
notice anything different about my
facial region I'm wearing our new Star
Wars inspired hat from nerd riot.shop
this is all orabesh baby you let us know
in the comment section down below what
this says we've got also new Mando
inspired merch over at nerdwyatt dot
shop for you and the nerdy people in
your family that you love so hit up
nerdrive.shop today but alright gang
let's start this off by analyzing what
king the Conqueror told his army during
his big speech in quantumania that would
ultimately be really interrupted by a
rebellious teenager trying to inspire
the people to rise up against their
oppressive dictator as the youth these
days like to do king says and I quote
today we ascend from this Fortress I
will take my revenge on those who
banished me today we conquer
eternity and the dynasty of Kang and
then he gets cut off this is where we
learn Kang's ultimate goal he wants
revenge on the Council of kings that we
meet at the end of the movie for
banishing him to the quantum realm and
his plan to do that by conquering
eternity the cosmic god of the entire
Marvel Cinematic Cosmos that we met in
Thor love and thunder just sitting there
meditating on stuff but how would one go
about conquering eternity and why does
Kang have a beef with a person that
looks like outer space can you even
punch a dude with no face to put it
simply I think this is because
eternity is a living Cosmic cage and a
cage that determines the fate of
everyone in all of Marvel Cinemas
because if you remember from Ant-Man and
the lost quantumania Kang cannot stand
being caged and King says what I believe
to be one of the most important
quantumania Alliance when he tells Janet
time is not what you think it is it's a
cage and it does everything it can to
break you it's not until you free
yourself from it that you can see just
how small it always was Kang hates being
caged and he wants to escape outside of
Eternity like Gore and the Thor's
managed to do briefly in 411 Thunder
through the secret Asgardian shortcut
that is through the heart of Eternity
they use Stormbreaker to make that
shortcut to get outside of Eternity
because if you look at eternity's
physical form you'll see that within
eternity's body lies the entire infinite
Marvel Cosmos and Eternity is much
bigger than you might imagine everything
looks like outer space within eternity's
body because eternity is all of Marvel's
cinematic space listen guys watching
something that you love is self-care and
it feels good right well with geology
you can have that good feeling of
self-care in your daily routine too
geology is a 16-time award-winning
personalized skin care company
recognized in men's health Esquire and
ask men grouping Awards with over 6 000
5 Star reviews just take a quick 30
second diagnostic quiz and geology will
create a simple and effective skin care
or hair care routine customized just for
you with ingredients that are
dermatologist tested proven to work and
personalized to your needs for Hair Care
geology's got strengthening shampoo and
conditioner and co-wash things that I do
not need
[Music]
which will transform your routine and
deliver the best hair of your life it
extends the time between washes and
replaces the need for so many products
so you wash your hair less and save
money they also offer body washes and
deodorants which I can use that are free
of harsh ingredients and smell great for
skincare the heavy covered from all
angles fight acne reduce oiliness
prevent wrinkles combat dark or puffy
under eyes have smoother hydrated skin
and Target signs of aging their daily
personalized skincare routine comes with
two face washes morning face cream
retinol night cream and eye cream and
right now for a limited time you can get
a five piece trial set for only 15 if
you use code rockstar70 at checkout
that's over fifty dollars of product for
just 15 and on top of that you'll get an
additional bonus offer on one of their
brand new skin hair and body products of
your choice when you add it to your
trial so to get started just click the
link in the description and remember to
use the code rockstar70 at checkout and
we thank John D for sponsoring this
video but what do I mean when I say all
of Marvel's cinematic space I'm mean I'm
talking more than just the Marvel
Cinematic Universe run by Kevin feige in
Marvel Studios the Marvel Cinematic
Universe is just a tiny marble in an
infinite sea of something much bigger
much bigger than anyone could ever
imagine
eternity is just one big cage made up of
an infinite amount of black hole reality
cages and Kang absolutely hates Eternity
for that remember how in the beginning
of the Loki finale we get that massive
zoom out of those two black holes before
zooming in on this black hole on the
right to see the Citadel at the end of
time these black holes are the reality
bubbles of time that Kang told Janet
were cages these are the cages each of
these black hole reality bubbles holds
their own Multiverse tree of timelines
with their own Multiverse tree gardening
Force like the TVA or even the great
Weaver if you're in the spider-verse
reality with this reality bubble on the
right being the MCU reality bubble
housing he who remains a sacred timeline
Multiverse tree everything that has
happened so far in Kevin feige's Marvels
in Cinematic Universe has taken place in
this reality bubble on the right holding
the Loki season 1 secret timeline now
under Sylvie's management it is within
this sacred timeline Multiverse tree
that Dr Strange and America Chavez
journey across as they fly into the MCU
reality bubble in Multiverse of Madness
pontomania is of course an exception to
this because quantumania takes place in
Kang's Quantum realm prison a prison
that Kang feels eternity influenced the
Council of Kang's actions to put him in
however the MCU Marvel reality with that
sacred timeline is just one reality in
all of Marvel Cinema that is just Kevin
feige's MCU reality bubble or reality
cage depending on if you're cageophobic
like hey I believe that there are an
infinite amount of These reality bubbles
that make up eternity why because you
gotta remember kids Marvel Studios is
not the only entity that makes Marvel
movies with their own reality Sony and
20th Century Fox have had their own
reality bubbles as well eternity
specifically made all of these reality
cages to keep the Marvel cinematic
Cosmos organized but eternity also had
another selfish goal to make sure that
eternity was always the number one
baller shot caller for every reality
within themselves because eternity knew
that in an infinite multi-multiverse
Challengers to his throne would
eventually come you know Challengers
like dormammu and ego The Living Planet
with the latter even showing Star-Lord
the complete Cosmic scope of Eternity as
ego planned to expand and Ascend across
every reality bubble to eventually
become
eternity themselves like that was
literally ego's plan because ego is
eternity's brain tumor like he was
Meredith Quill's tumor and the Guardians
had to you know scoop that out and this
is why I believe the web of life and
Destiny and across the spider verse and
into the spider-verse looks like a
variant of the Sacred timeline from Loki
that's because it basically is Sony's
animated spider-verse has their own
reality bubble with its own Multiverse
tree and thus its own 616 timeline tree
branch the MCU and the spider verse each
have a 616 cause there are different
trees in different reality bubbles but
in Sony's reality the cosmic
spider-verse Multiverse tree is known as
the web of life and Destiny and it's
what these spider people will journey
across like Loki and across the
spider-verse it's why we will not see
them cross over in any MCU realities for
all we know right now this reality
bubble on the left of the MCU reality
bubble could be Sony spider-verse
reality boat but my money is that that
particular bubble belongs to the 20th
Century Fox X-Men reality we don't
officially know what the fox Multiverse
tree looks like yet but I have a feeling
that that weird looking branching
timeline that the Council of Kings
manage at the end of the quantumania
movie is probably that fox X-Men
Multiverse tree inside of the fox X-Men
reality bubble black hole when Kane
tells the lokies that he found realities
stacked on top of each other he uses
imagery of three black holes Kang was
literally referring to the infinite
unique black hole reality bubbles that
make up the multi-multiverse that is
eternity and what's quantumania became
conquered his reality and found out that
there was even more he grew to hate the
very concept of Eternity as a cosmic
cage and wanted to ascend out of
eternity's big-ass space body completely
so he could tell eternity what to do for
once every Marvel movie that starts with
an in association with Marvel title card
exists in a black hole reality bubble
outside of Kevin feige's sacred timeline
reality bubble because they were
realities made by entities outside of
Marvel Studios like Sony or 20th Century
Fox I believe that quantumania King's
ultimate goal is to attack and Conquer
every single Marvel Cinematic reality
bubble in order to conquer eternity From
the Inside Out in order to hopefully one
day Escape eternity itself but thank you
guys so much for watching this video you
can follow me at Mass retainment on
Twitter but more importantly you can
follow rockstars wherever we are on
social medias thank you guys again for
spending time with me I love you guys so
much and I'll see you guys next time
goodbye
thank you